it is now time for our second feature
bout of the evening a best-of-five
left-handed match between two of the
best left-handed arm wrestlers on the
planet approaching the table first he
stands at 6 feet 2 inches tall and
weighed in at 297 pounds he's competing
out of South Paulo Brazil he's dominated
these super heavyweight division beating
some of the biggest names in the sport
along the way he is one of the most
animated and passionate competitors on
the circuit is mildly crazy can you
imagine that dude climbing up the power
book when you just got sentenced to
eight months in prison for riding your
bike without lights
and his opponent standing at six feet
six inches tall and weighing in at to
177 pounds competing out of Big Island
Ontario with an outstanding record of 34
wins and only four losses he is a fan
favorite and multiple time wal champion
considered by many to be the best ever
to pull and a future hall-of-famer
he is no
limits didn't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and he's making his way to the table
this is the biggest version of devon
we've ever seen 277 pounds of him he's
getting bigger he's getting stronger
he wants the statement but in black know
for tomahto
it's facing another child water water
he's ready he's the bigger man in terms
of weights and there's no body fat on
Wagner bought a lot so this guy has got
the body fat of a pool ball well said
cash on the table to the table
left-handed match here one of our
feature matches this leads up to our
main event
this should be fun meal Devon has
already started the mine when they went
to shake comes there he tried to drag
mortal out all off center but let me
tell you mortal our toes grip is insane
shock comes with this dude earlier today
in the hotel and I felt my god damn
shoelaces tighten thumb then I say hey
bro never some well he doesn't speak
English Portuguese is his native tongue
and Wagner bought a lottery so surely
stumps he wants to make
they drive their gelato not straight to
destroy the entire building
wait the showman the thing is mortal
otto is like this all the time yeah when
you meet him outside away from the arm
wrestling table he's the quietest most
humble endearing guy you could ever meet
the kind of guy you'd you know invite
into your house to sleep with your wife
but when he gets to an arm-wrestling
table getting its ferocity unleash it's
as passionate says love it's already
started and you can see as Jordi Lara
yes it's a big smile on her face there
that she can see your husband that mind
games
has already started he needs to be
careful here because he's got a tiger by
the tail if he allows boards a la tool
to connect Devon come down I'll tell you
what he's gonna know he's in an arm
wrestling match yep Brazil's finest
incredibly powerful individual this is a
[Applause]
2010 you said this morning when you were
giving me a little background on him and
an arm or surveys that's correct West
and what he sees about war two little
boys look like a giant blacksmith just
numb that farm power you know Country
Strong yeah this guy was 9 when he was
born
here we go drive sets up but look at
that from Lera he's got the horsepower
he stays risen North Alonso trying to
reconnect with that wrist needs to be
patient staying with it and gather his
arm doesn't want to burn out and this is
a bleed now for too long toys from
Brazil he's very familiar with the
Anaconda devil era right
[Applause]
the mistake he will squeeze he will
tighten and they'll try to choke the
line
[Applause]
being spanked
honey man really for also team cares
[Applause]
real they're incredible hi Lauren
collects leaves behind his arm and
finishes with a breath
the sweats fills up the face [ __ ] no
more colossal ferocity in that first
rawr so visceral longest full of the
night movie so far 37 seconds it seemed
a lot longer than that enormous thing
you've got two types of on this way
you've got a predator Mike the mortal
auto is a predator you've got a hunter
Devin Lara is the hunter and he brought
the sniper rifle tonight he's already
back up ready to go is Larry yeah he's
doing that he learned a lesson from
Michael talk out
[Music]
[Applause]
and forget that shut out the noise lay
into the crowd the crowds into it with
Devin take your time bort Alonzo because
if you go back up there now yes
Lara wants the bleep he's trying to
utilize the weapon of choice to make
sure he takes away that explosive attack
the Wagner is Devon's talking to him out
there oh yeah he'll use it were they on
rock trying to get into his mind trying
to me up mortal I'll come back to the
table early if I was bought a lot oh I'd
be thinking of ways to come up late a
little prayer there he's back up
1-nothing lead for Devin
I'm water portal our total revenue so
forth yep those are loved needs to get
some connection in this way it needs to
land on top of them
Devon's stretching out and you know what
in that first round it looked to me like
Devon run very close to a John star he
was away so earlier here they drive and
this time Wartortle stays a little
tighter but look at the face yes there's
the squeeze now he'll apply all the
pressure is survivors hound at that
point Magna needs to tighten needs to
stay with his arm don't expose the
humerus the leverage the height and
length of the forearm of Devon gives him
so many options and he'll try to make
minor adjustments is the much per se
test difference had always been for a
battement
he's moving down to one - this morning
moves down and trash there are the risk
of mortality up that's a brave move with
mortal ATO strength in the joint long
grinding brutal for 45 seconds of
Saturday but you can see there the
fatigue factor that puts on terrain
bassy Stefan Lara yep he scoped the gust
up and to nothing lead for no limits as
you call him the Canadian Ferrari and
jonah lehrer always cheered on her
husband you know what he feels like
she's gonna go home with no little money
at this point we're working on that he's
one went away from it you know what
master class of our breasts are from
Devin Lara there he has found ways to
draw portal art or into a dogfight in
positions that he didn't realize he was
in a truck Wagner was in a truck from
the moment the man stopped and he baited
him Devin allowed Wagner to walk into
those traps look at the hand and wrist
position in there that illustrates the
confidence of Devin and he uses that
joint strength once he feels the
strength level of bought a lotto drop he
allowed him to get to a manageable level
of strength transition to the press
great arm resting from the Dan move
finished him off you know what he wanted
to through his house lied about this
risk because he wanted to test the
strength
[Applause]
the big day that's between master men
right now he's experienced in this form
of handling all those but I don't know
he gets hard hour to get away from the
counter ten seconds here Bart would
board a lot Oh taking every single
second and then some as he should
yeah to the table no question summoned
by Bart to the table now Devon larren
trying to make it a clean sweep here he
comes up there and he leave everything
on the table bortolotti will blow on his
shield he'll give every ounce but I just
don't think it's enough eat he's now got
a massive level of a tea and lactic acid
out of his arm and it won't go away he
needs to always needs more chalk because
he's sweating like a chip yep incredible
amount of energy incredible amount of
effort footed by Wagner he couldn't have
tried any harder it's just he he running
to bear traps from start to finish up
that man is that good it really is I
mean you know you guys kingdoms got his
critics out there let me tell you what
that Devin Lara is a very very complete
arm wrestler he's also an extremely
strong arm wrestler and in terms of
physicality he's an incredibly difficult
guy to deal with he's got all the
weapons he needs long forearm tremendous
joint strength good balanced technique
he can pull in any position the top roll
the hot the press even the kings move
look I face immortal yeah I gotta have
over 50 seconds
[Music]
there we go a little bit of bumps are
there between yes Devin and Lord yes you
know what I don't think it matters for
Devin now I think he can relax I think
he's burned enough energy now out of his
opponent
really he can have his way come on
huge hit one bar earlier yes come on
over here as I said Devin yeah finish
the game he's about ever there's the pin
Wow
don't mess with giant Jesus you let this
match up on top
[Applause]
back aboard too long so just went nuts
he got a slight shake a daylight there
because Devin let out too much rope he
let out the rope he let out the rope
well I'll tell you Walt Magnum Ortolan
so hasn't read the script and he took
that pin on pure determination honor
percent afford a lot of gas but he gets
that one to stay alive making it 2-1
look at this on the replay dibbler could
have finished that much you've been let
me to take that I ain't gonna do but he
fed him role be fed in row and when you
do that with a man with this one joint
strength if he gets connected
he will make you pay and you can see we
went from comfortable to holy what our
might idea and there was the pin yep
giant Jesus lands a pin and goes
completely bananas yeah he's like oh you
let it go to poor me and you may get
burned came all the way from Brazil you
know what he really is no I got their
boardwalk so it's a lovely person yeah
just the most
[Music]
[Applause]
is really gassed still alive though two
one yeah down to 12 seconds left on it
Neal I expect I expect Devon to play a
little less games though I'm right there
with you
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right both men back to the table
[Applause]
pad feature match trying to knock him
out in for what man will describe
actually hot wait to see buddy had
something in this matter
no he deserved it just from the sheer
effort that he's put in there this trap
he said no to the table hey Viking abort
salon so I wasn't read any scripts here
alright
a one thing you can tell from the gospel
portal lotsa was prepared to leave it
all on the table he run into that with
material with tendon with ligament you
know he he's putting it in there hard
Devon's gonna make sure that he doesn't
get carried away right just calm down a
little and keep control Dolan was
getting it out of out of control on you
[Applause]
as we expected but he felt enough from
black lift a bit you know what this
isn't a guy I'm gonna give anymore let's
put it away Wiseman
and you never know devil Iron Man just
earned himself a few more pounds because
tonight Yano Kingsmill he went in
various positions we saw the inside
techniques we saw the top roll
we saw the range of technique this